30s
did
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value giv vales contagious
this world of entrepreneurs we get no
value to ha Romie look what I become I'm
the okay so I don't know how often we do
podcasts on a Saturday night at 1 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time right now right
cuz we're in we're in Phoenix right now
but we invited we were invited to uh
this event by this guy who uh is a very
special guy he's got how many people
make some noise everybody make some
noise they're here they're here I don't
know 13,000 people in the room Insanity
at Turning Point USA we got Adam here we
got bisoc Tom we got Vinnie and the
great Charlie Kirk in the house give it
up for Charlie ladies and gentlemen sick
event Charlie absolutely I got to tell
you one of the things I learned about
you today which I had no idea I did not
know your uh grandmother voted
Republican her entire life and ever
since she's died that's right she's Dem
Democrat that's right ever
congratulations every every year that's
a joke YouTube that's a joke everybody I
don't want people to uh go so Charlie
how you feel right now with the you got
you know we uh first of all credit to
the staff uh the Turning Point USA staff
they work their tail off uh they work
all year first on campuses and in
churches and this is a culmination of
all it it's a celebration of the
Grassroots Army that we've built at
Turning Point USA but pbd you host
amazing events honored to speak at one
last a couple months ago you know what
it takes to put on events like this uh
and to have to execute on a standard of
Excellence uh like the Turning Point
team does is not easy and I'm so
thankful for our team um from the
graphic design team to the social media
team to people that have been here
literally sleepless nights for a week to
make sure that everyone here can have a
uh life-changing experience so I'm
thrilled for our team um glory be to God
he's blessed us amazingly here it's the
biggest event uh multi-day event in
conservative history and also obviously
the biggest event in Turning Point USA
history that's powerful to hear that
seeing the energy and by the way if
you're here you know what I'm talking
about if you not if you saw it online it
was absolutely
electrifying uh we want to get into some
topics we're doing podcast right we got
some stories uh one of the stories I
think we can get into we'll get into
here in a minute is what Kobe C said
about LeBron James not standing up in
the NBA game the standing ovation we'll
talk about that there was some
extracurricular activity uh by a senate
staffer I don't know if you guys heard
about this is that what you call is that
what you call it yeah by a senate
staffer alleged allegedly by
conservative Outlets to have had sex in
a hearing room hold on read that how
sick is that headline though Senate
Stafford this is by NBC News the word
allegedly when it was on video
conservative Outlets to have had out
have to do with this all of a sudden
they're making it into a rightwing thing
we'll talk about that we'll talk about
that to see what's going on Zuckerberg
is building $100 million house in Hawaii
compound with massive underground bunker
maybe he watched this movie Leave the
World Behind and he's a little concerned
or Civil War who knows musk is starting
a university I wonder how people feel
about it we'll talk about that I think
he's putting a $100 million into it IBM
did you see the IBM video that was
released by the way James O'Keefe is
here at America Fest and we should have
his back he's had a tough year and he
just posted a big win that was a massive
win we'll talk about that as us mortgage
payments on a new home have seen 90%
rise under Biden's uh uh presidency and
then we got a couple other stories we'll
get into one of the ones I want to get
into which is kind of an interesting
story they ran numbers on the top 10
male models what they make in total
versus top 10 female Mo models again Top
10 male models top 10 female models what
the 10 make against each other and I
think it's unfair if you ask me from
your face I can tell from your I can
tell when you look at the numbers I
think we need to do something about it
so we we need Congressional hearings I
agree so so before we talk about that
stuff let's first go to our sponsor Rob
if you want to play this clip American
Harford gold and we'll get on to all
these stories so look I've been in the
financial industry since 911 the day
before 911 and I've owned stocks bonds
mutual funds real estate crypto gold you
name it I've owned it but the one thing
that's very important part of my
portfolio all these years is gold I love
having a percentage of my network in
Gold that I have access to in case of
many different things that's why we
chose to work with our new sponsor
American hardford Gold if you have
retirement funds that you cannot afford
to lose American Harford gold will ship
physical gold or silver directly to your
door also if you have retirement funds
that you can't afford to lose now is the
time to call American hardford gold a
precious metal dealer you can trust they
have the finest products amazing
customer service and a buyback
commitment they've earned a five star
rating from thousands of reviews and an
A+ from the Better Business Bureau tell
them I send you and they'll send you up
to $5,000 worth of free silver on your
first order so click on the link in the
description or call
866939 6984 again 866 939
6984 all right are we back Rob are we
good okay so let's go into the story
here first one IBM has a secret weapon
that's bringing in billions the mly fool
IBM strategy involves selling clients on
its platform the open shift let me see
if this is the story you're not
Rob that's not the one R the story about
IBM is what the James o'keef did it's
because of this okay let me go through
this okay IBM strategy involves selling
clients on its platform like open shift
and Watson X which generates a
multiplier effect CFO Jim Kavanaugh
revealed that every $1 of Revenue spend
on these platform results in $3 and $5
additional spending on SP on software
and between $6 and $8 additional on on
uh Services rap I don't know if this
story matches the other actually I can
connect the two though pbd because it's
really it's super important okay so then
let me read the whole thing and then
I'll turn it over to you IBM while
offering its own public clown Computing
uh platform partners with leading
technology companies like AWS Microsoft
and others these Partnerships have
driven significant bookings for IBM with
Kavanaugh stating our strategic
partnership we've got multibillion
dollar book of business with WS with
Microsoft and sa and samp and next up
are going to be Salesforce with Oracle
and Adobe coming up so tell us more
about the story so so that story didn't
get a lot of headlines about AI it's
developing but what the other IBM story
is which is going viral thanks to James
O'Keefe is this one where IBM was caught
on camera uh their CEO saying give
bonuses only to Black employees and
don't give them to white people we
should actively discriminate against
white people America First legal has um
slammed IBM they're potentially going to
sue over at title six complaint so what
do the two have to together right
anti-white attitudes IBM and
AI tell us well AI it's who who's going
to write the ethics and the morals of
the AI of tomorrow so a AI is going to
become a woke super weapon oh so
think about it who's going to tell AI
right from wrong well the code of ethics
that govern IBM is going to be infused
into the operating protocol of AI so
that's story doesn't seem like it's
related okay they have a press release
they're making all this money on AI so
let's pretend you go into the AI that
IBM is developing a chat GPT gbt type
model right yeah you ask the question
can black people be racist and the IBM
aai would eventually say no they would
say uh what is racism and they'd say
racism is not individual prejudice but a
power struggle of what I'm getting at is
that to seemingly disconnected stories
here IBM making a ton of money on AI and
their woke culture this is the danger
the the clear and present danger of
artificial intelligence is less about
Terminator that's a thing but it's more
about giving the woke mind virus a
thermonuclear weapon to redesign Society
because at some point something has to
tell the AI what is true and what is
good and the IBM code of ethics I kid
you not I have it in front of me and you
guys can look it up IBM has a like a Ten
Commandments Elon Musk just responded to
this a Ten Commandments a a a Dei 10
commandments alley ship Commandments
this is IBM openly acknowledge privilege
and systemic racism exist and result in
trauma two never question the reality of
our black friends and colleagues three
reject the idea that race is political
except that white people are responsible
for dismantling racism five
understanding only white people are
racist this is an official document of
IBM IBM's document can Rob can you pull
this up so we can show this to the
audience if you have this document sit
right there this is O'Keefe broke the
story number six knows the black
community owes us nothing in this work
seven require acknowledgement and repair
of inevitable mistakes eight is never
rooted in white saviorism nine sees the
black community as a group of
individuals and not as a monolith 10
does not seek recognition or praise for
a job well done so this is called alley
ship so I want to just emphasize one of
them and I was just spotting up to my
head no understanding that only white
people are racist that is the Ten
Commandments of IBM so the Ten
Commandments of IBM are quietly going to
be inputed into the AI of tomorrow
that's connecting those two stories
Patrick AI is becoming a woke super
weapon this this won't work though
because this is again another one of
those ideas that's just not going to
work folks if you're looking at this
online Rob can you do me a favor play
the first minute of O'Keefe's clip while
the CEO of IBM is speaking we just want
to play the first arid Krishna yeah goad
and some low person the co ofm go ahead
so we take under represented and gender
you got to move both forward by a
percentage that leads to a Plus on your
bonus by the way if you lose you lose
part of your bonus I'm not trying to
finesse this so for blacks we should try
to get towards 13 something per on
Hispanics you got to get into the mid
but let me say it Asians in the US are
not an underrepresented minority in a
tech company James o'keef here outside
of IBM's corporate headquarters in armun
New York an IBM Insider has provided us
with an internal video showing the CEO
of IBM arban Krishna using coercion to
fire people and take away their bonuses
unless they discriminate in the hiring
process let me go deeper in the red hat
multiple leaders over the last year plus
that were held accountable to the point
that they're no longer here at Red Hat
because they weren't willing to live up
to the standards that we set in this
space this conversation takes place
every single day and and a lot of it's
behind the scenes they terminated
Executives that didn't discriminate yet
another violation of title 7 one of the
biggest companies in the world one of
the most valuable and recognizable
brands on
Earth IBM Insider has provided us with
an internal video showing the CEO of IBM
arban Krishna using coercion to fire
people you can pause it here you can
pause it here so um okay Tom here's a
question for you I got I got a question
for you you you've been around a block
and a company this is a Dow 30 company
they're worth $150 billion they're not a
small company they're $150 billion
company they may do something like this
is this this is as of when Rob this is
one day 148 billion how was right yeah
can you do me a favor go to a five day
go to five days to see what happens to
their stock not a big movement go to one
month to see what's happened really not
a big they're up over the last year by
the they're up 40% over the last year
how how uh suain go to five years yeah
Tom how sustainable is this to have
ideas like this within a company as big
as IBM well first of all Charlie makes a
good point I'll connect back to do you
and just just quick yes or no and we'll
nod here do you remember when chat GPT
first came out and kids were asking it
like questions and then people ask
questions about faith and suddenly it
was clear that chat gbt had a bias
remember this we all discovered it and
it was it was almost uh seen as you know
no big deal nothing to see here you're
just using chat gbt online to get
something answered oh wow it's got a
bias now you can see where the bias goes
how deep it goes but let me tell you
take you know my first job out of
college was with IBM I went to IBM sales
School finish number one in my classes
you you know you know what back then
that it this didn't exist there was a
thing on the wall simply said respect
for the individual whoever the
individual was just respect for the
individual this is what year time what
year is this this is 1987 and right
underneath it it says our motto is
simply think and that's where it was and
that company has has devolved CEO head
on his desk just think think and that's
what it was that's devolved I don't
think this is survivable long term the
company IBM's not going away but it's
not survivable in its current state it's
going to change it's going to be hit
because you know what if IBM has an
office in Oklahoma there's a certain
Governor that just signed an executive
order you can't do this specifically and
there's a Supreme Court case this year
that started with the um Asian suing uh
Yale Yale Yale for Yale for admission
they lost and they went to the Supreme
Court and then we got the uh the
anti-discrimination in admissions it's
all connected IBM this is going to cause
cracks some people have they they can't
continue this it's not sustainable in
its current you know how they say you
know go woke go broke what's actually
going to happen to IBM what are the
ramifications of something like this
coming out Charlie yeah it's it's not
like Bud Light because there's not IBM
is not used by the everyday person right
IBM is a lot of um tailored type of
contracts it's literally called
International Business Machines that's
what IBM stands for and that red hat is
their Hiring Agency red hat is the tech
sourcing firm for them so what's going
to happen I don't know but it should be
a reminder that as we Barrel towards
artificial intelligence we have to
figure out very simple answers to the
question of what is true what is good
what is right or wrong by what is the
code of ethics that we operate and this
is something that you look at what IBM
believes in they believe their 10
commandments are understand that only
white people are racist except that
white people are responsible for
dismantling racism so on and so forth
and so artificial intelligence is going
to be used as a way where an 8-year-old
is going to type in very basic questions
and they are going to socially reprogram
millions and tens of millions of people
and this is why Elon I think I think
Elon with his prophetic ability to see
things before they happen and immense
amount of Courage I'm a huge Elon fan I
think Elon what keeps Elon up at night
and the reason he's acting the way he is
is he's connecting dots woke mind virus
with AI he has said this as much where
what is going there will be a time where
you ask AI something and will give you
an answer as if it's authoritatively
true even though it
isn't can say one what so we we keep
hearing all this type of stuff you hear
see what IBM you just see this
anti-white rhetoric is happening there's
a war on white people well and here's my
thing what's the overall go like what
the hell are they trying to do like what
what what's going on they're AC trying
everywhere all over Europe everywhere
it's just an influx of everybody else
and and and to hell with us and to hell
with our country so part of it is very
masochistic there are some people that
just hate themselves honestly and
they've been told to hate themselves
filled with guilt it it's basically soow
Mo slow motion suicide however whiteness
is a filler term to just say power
structure those people in power right so
it is a Marxist framing of the world
oppress or oppressed and they say white
people are the majority therefore they
are in control um and we must try and
dismantle them look at the mayor of
Boston you're pulling it up right now uh
Boston woo uh who has segregated
Christmas parties where white people are
not allowed by the way there are black
only dormitories at dozens of colleges
probably hundreds now dozens that I know
of black only dormitories um and this is
where it ends up it ends into this
really sick racial apartheid state where
white people have less rights I'll give
you another example when monocolonal
antibodies were distributed in the city
of New York until they got caught they
were prioritizing people of color in the
city of New York life-saving monoclonal
antibodies were distributed and were
prioritized to people of color and white
people had to wait now they got caught
it's against the law and you know they
ret they retreated go look up the new
University of Michigan hypocritic oath
where the doctors and nurses of tomorrow
see look at that New York City will
consider race when Distributing
life-saving covid treatments so where
are we heading we are headed to an AI
based social credit system where if you
are white you have points docked against
you that if you're a person of color you
get special tokens this is a
reconfiguration of racial apartheid it's
the death of meritocracy and it's a
backdoor way to destroy Western
Civilization because Western
Civilization is against this crap it's
against the toxicity that Race Matters
one more thing on this topic so a month
ago maybe even two weeks ago they can
hear us now hi everybody see now we can
get some Spirit going right Fant I'm
glad we got that night and day yes
that's good shout out to James o'keef
because why is this so important a month
ago not even less a month ago the
biggest story in the news was what what
was going on with chat GPT and Sam
ultman right the Hostile takeover of the
company in he was out he was in he was
out now he's back in officially but
these types of conversations especially
around AI need to be had now the sooner
the better for the sake of humanity yes
and so the what Elon wants is he says
why can't we have an AI that is not
program political as if you're asking
MSNBC the questions or you're asking
Nicole Hanah Jones you're asking Robin
D'Angelo that's a good goal whether it's
achievable or not and so Patrick that's
a question is the question for you
because you alluded to this we didn't
really land the plane is this popular is
this going to continue here's the issue
the regular people here at America Fest
by the way people of all different skin
colors and backgrounds and diversity
they think this is terrible the question
though is that the elites they're buying
into this the elites are bought into an
anti-white anti-western anti-christian
agenda this is going to reach a boiling
point because the the Grassroots the
people aren't putting up with it this is
a top down Revolution I don't disagree I
don't think it's sustainable I don't
think it's going to work I think it
needs to piss off uh the people who are
wanting to fight for and stand up kind
of like what Elon is doing we talked
about it earlier today where there is
three different ways to contribute one
is with your time one is with your money
one is with your voice if you have a
platform talk about it if you got time
give your time to somebody if you got
the money make the right investments
into companies that want to do something
about this and that's what Elon Musk is
doing Elon just spent $100 million I
want you to think about this he put $100
million into a new UN University Elon
wants to open up a new University in
Texas this is according to the story uh
The Verge so Elon Musk plans to
establish a university in Austin Texas
with a $100 million contribution from
his charity the foundation the
university will focus on stem education
and offer instruction in subjects like
math science engineering and physics it
aims to provide Hands-On learning
experiences and simulations while
seeking accreditation
from Southern Association of Colleges
and Schools commissions on colleges in
addition to the university musk's plan
includes building stem focused primary
and secondary school schools that will
teach subject Beyond stem these K
through 12 schools will initially enroll
around 50 students with the intention of
scaling up over time this is an example
of somebody that's making their money
and using their money to fight the
elites when you see Elan doing something
like this time for somebody whose
daughter we cannot publicly say it yes
or no we cannot say it or we can't say
it don't say the school don't say the
school okay Tom's daughter had a school
she wanted to go to yeah I'll give you
where it's at it's in America okay
narrows
it specific not Oxford no it's not
Oxford she got a 1560 out of her 1600 as
a parent time when you hear somebody
like Elon Musk who's got few hundred
million he's putting $100 million into
schools what does that make you think
about because if he's the pay or maybe
other people are going to say I want to
start my my own school as well what does
this make you think about well this this
makes me think about and I I've had this
discussion with my daughter and my wife
and I said I think you're the last
generation that goes at least from our
family into a traditional education
institution as we know the structure
today I don't think my grandkids will do
this I think that you have people like
Elon Musk like you and me that feel
passionate about education that are
going to build a Next Generation a next
level of Education in America and what I
think about I really think this is
the the last generation at least I'm
going to be involved with that that goes
through these traditional colleges in a
traditional way and and by the way it's
really sketchy right now you know but
she's got a very specific major she
wants to go follow that but that's what
I think about I got a question and I
love what he's doing I love what he's
doing I want to support him let's be
creative let's be creative and let's get
some ideas here okay let's just say we
have an unlimited checkbook we can use
some of our resources to start a school
what would you build as a school to be
unique and different than other schools
out there how would you build a school
what would you do in your school this
goes to everybody here Tom I'll start
off with you I I'd go right back to the
tradition of debate because debate has
become you know just loud argument there
is a tradition of debate where you had a
elegant way and there was rules of
debate to come bring in a point have a
Counterpoint a rebuttal and then a
review by your peers at the conclusion
of that debate called the discussion of
your of your classmates or a discussion
by a panel
I would bring back debate of both sides
bringing both sides in so people could
see the logic and the true winner rather
than being told who the winner is Vinnie
what would you do serious I mean I
remember what pledge allegiance they
took did they take that out of school
too just something in the beginning
where you where you shot out your
country and you you basically get
everybody on the same team they stopped
doing all that Charlie you got a school
we're whatever we want to call the
school we can call it what would you
have in your school that would be
different than other schools yeah first
I think Hillsdale does a great job uh
and I think Hillsdale is America's
greatest college and they're a sponsor
here and I I love them hillsdale.edu
they're amazing actually the website is
Charlie for hillsdale.com if you really
want to check it out but um I would make
a different I I would I would combine
Mind Body Soul um if you the theoretical
school is you have to be physically fit
uh you have to have a certain BMI you
have to commit to a spiritual life and
you also have to develop your mind and I
would do it in a classical way uh the
whole Center of higher education should
be that there is a truth and let's
figure out out what that is the reason
the woke stuff has started is they start
from a truth claim saying there is no
truth as soon as you acknowledge there's
an objective of truth of the universe it
destroys all woke I hope everyone
understands that how do you beat the
woke as soon as you get people to
acknowledge that there are natural laws
of the universe that transcend Your
Existence and some things are
objectively true it it absolutely o
obliterates the woke so as higher
education has dismissed that the woke
has been ascendant so that's what I
would do Adam let's by the way how many
you guys want to hear what Adam has to
say about the school anybody wants to
hear Adam thoughts here what would you
do with your school so I have a feeling
if Adam started a school yeah 9 10 ratio
I believe 100% you not 100% it' be like
a nightclub in Miami 90% women 10% guys
it's going to be the best college of all
time but with that being said number
rule number one rule number one no dudes
are allowed to play sports with the
females I like that straight up I like
that okay like just not happening idea
this is like man that's understand so
you're saying we will do like we did
back in the day and Little League Cup
check let's see what's going on here got
you number two when we started the
podcast in 2020 I think the number was
like 11 to1 liberal teachers yep versus
conservative teachers that's right 111
can we just get that back to an
equilibrium situation where there's an
equal amount like you talked about
debate conservatives liberals talk to
each other because what's going on with
these smartest useful idiots in the
world at Harvard MIT pen we're seeing
what's going on there these kids are
geniuses but they're being fed a ball of
crap from these teachers because how
many kids in college are actually going
to stand up and confront their teacher
on maybe some ideology that they
perceive as wrong they're going to shut
the f up and follow along and then just
go along that path so I think it's
problematic that there's so many
teachers that are just basically
indoctrinating kids there's no more
education is just indoctrination in
school now back in Florida State when I
was there playing ball having fun we
didn't really have to get into all this
uh woke situation they go to class in
Florida State no but Charlie that's how
you end up in a podcast with TVD and Pat
Pat I think especially in the younger
age like you what what what do cops walk
around that what about Arizona State guy
what are you talking about I didn't go
to college he didn't even go to college
yeah here go to college it's a scam
everybody college is a scam the
university system is broken the college
Deb is ridiculous a good book it's the
college scam the college scam you did
write a book about it P what what do
what do cops wear on their on their Jack
the cameras that body cam the body cam
kids up to a certain age like when
they're young I want body C all the they
have cell phones that's no no no I want
a c like you you as a parent to see what
the hell they're teaching the kids I
totally agree have a have a camera go
like a GoPro on your kid I want to hear
if I want to tap in during the day and
see what the hell you're teaching my kid
I want to be able to come in and watch
here's the best argument you drop your
dog off for Doggy Daycare and you can
log into an app to see if your golden
retriever is being pampered get abused
when you drop your kid off to a public
school you have a moral right to find
out what that teacher is teach thank you
and Charlie even if it's one camera in
the classroom if like you're a dad want
to sign up for me yeah if you're a dad
in your home Adam I want to be able to
just go okay what are they doing if you
go in there and everybody's wearing
rainbow and dancing around I'm
coming to the school you know what I
mean
Tom CL what the hell's going on you want
me to put this out there you
go Phoenix welcome to the West
people guys that's the first Middle
Eastern Cowboy ever I
love hey we put the college scam written
by Charlie Kirk here you got your book
autograph I want to hear your answer to
this question how would you you're not
going be form the
college sign but your hair still looks
good ask the question no yeah because
we've had this conversation before but I
think with Charlie here and obviously in
the light of this book what would you do
because you have four kids some may go
to college some some might go on a
sports scholarship you've thought about
this one that's going to be slightly
different here's what I'm doing if you
go to my school if if your kids are
going to my school I need your
involvement the parents involvement
period okay if the parent is not
involved your kids can't go to my school
because I'm going to need your help if
we're going to spend time challenging
your kids pushing them driving them you
have a certain responsibility every
month for you to come to school what do
you mean by this the kid the parents
need to parents are coming like Rodney
Dangerfield and back to school that's
not what I'm talking about I'm talking
about you're coming model that works in
the inner city charter school you're
coming to school because we're going to
also work on you becoming a better
parent because we're going to become
collectively with the team so we'll
update you hey let me tell you what's
going on here's what happened this week
this is what we're working on these are
the things that we want to talk about
what parents are working hey Johnny can
you tell us what you're doing with your
kids that your two kids that go to our
school to have straight A what are you
doing Mary can you share with us what
you're doing with with your kids that
they got straight A as well and then all
of a sudden you're like oh you guys
do that yeah that's a great idea I'm
going to use other parents that are
raising their kids well to develop other
parents that are also holding their kids
accountable this idea about let me send
my kids somewhere you do your thing with
the kids it's parents responsibility so
we would put a bit of the onus also on
the parents the focus would be
leadership development the way he had it
I love the idea but uh can I can I add
one more thing that I think is would be
right up your alley what's that I think
kids need to understand that their major
has an Roi attached to it and I think
they need to eliminate whatever Majors
have no like kids are going into 50
100,000 A4
million of debt before they even made a
dollar in their life and it turns out
that basket weaving or underwater sewing
I'm going to tell you does not make
money you know it's crazy though here's
here's one thing we're not even thinking
about like look at all the industries
that are about that have disrupted in
the past before okay look what this is
okay no I I never went to Columbia
University to be a you know podcast or
journalist we're here doing a podcast
people watch this millions of people
give their opinions thoughts do you know
some of these guys that are used to
reading a teleprompter right there yes
next today at 8:00 John J from the and
you're just kind of reading it yeah the
disruption did this to mainstream Media
newspapers internet Twitter social I
believe the next 10 20 30 years one of
the one of the Industries that's going
to be disrupted in ways we don't even
know ourselves is going to be education
and it's going to be so painful by the
way we saw what happened with MIT we saw
what happened with pen we saw what
happened with Harvard they didn't fire
the president gay right we're not going
to be doing that they redefined
plagiarism yesterday in their bylaws by
the way you know what I love I love that
they did that you know why if you're a
parent and you're still thinking Harvard
is the Pinnacle of school to go to you
are a fool this is not the same Harvard
of 20 30 40 years ago they're being
exposed that's the beautiful thing about
what's going on there now gentlemen I
have something I want to share with you
guys I don't want you to be offended or
upset but I think it's not fair and in
about two minutes I think you're going
to be very upset with this one area if I
were to ask you right now the top 10
male models in America how much they
make versus the top 10 female models a
year a year total what's the ratio let
me ask you one more time Top 10 male
models good-looking men right versus top
10 female models what do you think the
disparity is this is a travesty 10 to
one I'd say it's 75 to one 75 to1 Rob
can you please play this clip I wish you
guys could see it but you you'll be able
to hear it Rob go Ahad and play this
clip for us please 10 top earning mail
models earned a combined total of 8
million from September 2012 12 to
September 2013 a fraction compared to
the 83 million their female counterparts
raked in over the past year sha oy is
currently the world's highest paid male
supermodel earning 1.5 million last year
Gap this and it's there for a reason and
it's been there I don't think it can be
closed females for example have a lot of
platforms that they can use to jump off
of like Victoria Secret contracts
cosmetic contracts males don't have that
but o isn't complaining top 10 8 million
versus women 83 million 10 years ago do
you think folks do you think it's fair
that women top 10 women models make 10
times the amount of money top 10 men
make is that fair yes or no do you think
it's fair how is that fair why isir so
sexist are you not offended by this V I
don't like it the market decides men men
are visual that's that's one of that's
one of the main reasons I left the
industry I was like I'm not doing this
anymore by the way shout out to
Vinnie days Vinnie Vinnie just become
trans and go get the
paycheck Vinnie mulany ladies and gent
there anybody that knows about that it's
you will you sponsor my boobs I'll get a
really nice I'll get a rack $10,000
today so wait wait wait I I thought Iraq
was a country no notq not Iraq anyway so
you know you know what is funny though
as much as we're having fun with this
and we're joking around this is when
somebody sits there and says well look
who wants to go watch male models the
way they want to watch female models you
know back in the days there was Mr
Universe who follows bodybuilding
anybody who knows Mr Olympia no okay
back in the days used to be something
called Mr Universe and it was something
called Miss Universe guess what no
longer exists Mr Universe guess what
still exists today Miss Universe
unfortunately Miss Universe is being ran
by man today transwoman I don't know if
you guys have seen that video or noten
transen trans byen that's right but is
it still run he's still he she whatever
he's about to go bankrupt he bought it
for $20 million he's going bankrupt they
don't know what they're going to be
doing with it I wonder why this is
another example NBA instead of boobs
when you show the numbers somebody can
look at it and say give me a flipping
break it's the market capitalism
whatever's getting more eyeballs let
them play ball Adam well look this might
be a little controversial but this goes
down to basically what Charlie always
talks about traditional gender rules
it's no secret that women through all of
history have been be objects and men
have been success objects I live in
Miami believe me I see fat sloppy dudes
worth a billion dollars hanging out with
supermodels how did that thing work out
if you want to take if you want to look
at deeper thing in the numbers because
natal and I covered this look at the
disparity in the NBA versus the WNBA
talking about putting butts in seats the
top NBA guy makes $50 million a year
okay the top WNBA player gets a pack of
tzers and says goes make a layup baby I
think she makes maybe a 100 Grand so
it's the same if you want to use Sports
success as an analogy and a metaphor to
what's going on in modeling men in the
NBA are making 1050 million a year $5
million is the mid-level exception if
you're average 5 million bucks in
modeling I think Kendall Jenner Bella
Hadid Gigi Hadid these people are making
20 40 $50 million a year where hot bill
over here makes a cool Mill and that's
all he's going to get what's wrong with
hot bill there's nothing wrong with
good looking guy for me he's a good
looking guy all right let's go to the
next story this is the Senate story so
Senate Stafford you guys okay with this
Charlie I'm coming to you for ready for
this dudes oh yeah it's a subject matter
I'm really
[Music]
familiar I'm the subject matter
expert Senate staff are alleged by
conservative Outlets to no no no you got
to dwell on the headline you have to
well listen I'm reading what NBC if they
say it it's correct right if they said
you got to believe them no I know but
the fact that what the heck does a
conservative Outlet have to do with this
Charlie I know you are dying to give us
your feedback on this let me first read
the story now let me read it you're
right fired up folks uh Senate staffer
alleged by conservative Outlets to have
had sex in a hearing room is no longer
employed NBC news so Aiden a senate
staff Accused by conserva out and
engaging in sexual activity in a senate
hearing room has been confirmed as no
longer employed by the US Senate
according to a statement by you know his
office the allegation stem from a video
published by The Daily Caller claiming
to show a congressional Snapper involved
in sexual activity within a senate
hearing room now listen I don't know if
we want to show this clip or not but
I yes Rob Rob has been showing it to me
all day listen we're all grown up here
we're going to show you the clip and
you're going to like it if you haven't
seen it we're not going to show it to
you I'm sure you've seen it here's a
question I got for you when you see some
like this okay and by the way did you
see his response what he said I I have
the whole read his response the most
Millennial
response it's our fault he had gay sex
in the Senate hearing it's homophobic
how dare you make this and you will be
held accountable by a court of law for
judging me and by the way can we at
least show an image we don't need to see
the video no no no so uh this has been a
difficult time for me as hold I'm going
to read it like him as I've been
attacked for who I love to pursue this
political agenda while some of my
actions in the past have shown per
judgment I love my it would never
disrespect my workplace any attempts to
characterize my actions otherwise are
fabricated all right and I will see by
exploring what legal options are
available to me in these matters wait
wait fabrication no no called
fornication Tom that's what it is
thoughts on this charart yeah man this
is Sodom I mean pure and simple this is
Sodom and Gomorrah stuff I mean we will
be judged I mean the the desecration the
depravity of what was once sacred but
honestly this is a pattern the what is
Holy and in Hebrew holy means separate
elevated is being desecrated on a daily
basis Joe Biden had uh alleged not
alleged but not this like transgender
stripper goes topless on the White House
lawn alleged by conservative no no no me
meaning alleged being I don't use the
word transgender I think it's all fake
but um the the right there right the Joe
Biden stripper on the White House lawn
they had that was trans day right or
Pride day they had the pride flag Center
Stage uh Dylan Mulaney is given special
access into the White House cocaine is
being done in the west wing it shouldn't
surprise us that Senate staffers are not
just having gay sex in the Senate
hearing room they are filming it they're
filming it and then he has the G yeah or
some
Anatomy it's our fault Patrick how dare
you how dare dare you you you made me do
this look what you made me do look what
you made me do you made me have live by
the way let me just be hold on one a
second this is this is a pattern I'm
seeing from the media the very similar
look at the political Story by the way
of the Virginia House candidate it came
out recently Virginia House candidate
sex tape um this whole profile piece in
Politico yep that's right here uh no
should be more recent yeah this is it
her online sex life was exposed she lost
her election now she's speaking up
nowhere do they mention she live
streamed it she live Streed her sex life
they didn't find it on some sort of
internet thing Rob get the link she
posted no stop
it stop it this is a family by the way
can somebody help find Vin and Adam a
wife please this is America Fest
familyfriendly wholesome got it think
homeschool okay that's America Fest this
we're out of Miami okay got it what's
wrong with Miami Charlie no there's
plenty wrong with
Miami anyway the point is this is a
pattern okay the degeneracy the
depravity ask you a question Charlie how
how does the enemy how does the enemy
process this so let let's just say x
China Iran Russia looks at us good what
do you think they see what does the see
this so I we know it I mean if you read
Putin's speeches again I'm not like a
big Putin fan but you should know he
uses it as an internal rallying cry to
consolidate power and this is something
that we need to talk I said this all
along that the subtext of the Ukraine
war is like gay agenda versus
traditional
if you read the actual Russian
Federation speeches Putin says they're
transing their kids and they're
chemically again I'm not aan of Russia
it's not a free Society it's not an
ideal Society but it's true that the
trans thing is pushed by NATO it's
pushed by our Intel agen the pride flag
is shown prominently by our government
and if you look if you actually read
deeper the spokesperson for zalensky was
a transperson for the last two years so
in some ways Russia uses this as an
excuse to say hey people of Russia I
guarantee you and they're by the way
they're going to show this like non-stop
if you R watch RT which I don't if you
watch any of these Russian television
stuff I guarantee you they're going to
say see look at the Americans this is
why we have to reject the West you have
to understand the The Narrative going on
in the East is that America is the
leader of modernity and modernity gets
you the following gets you live stream
gay sex in your Capital it gets you lots
of suicide it gets you a lot of
depravity it gets you lower birth rates
it gets you pornography it gets you
transgendering of kids some of that is
true some of it's an exaggeration but
what do our enemies the easy answer is
that they're laughing at us no no no no
you just gave Vladimir Putin a gift
where he is now going to give a speech
and say by the way the people financing
this war against you where you people of
Russia where they took the vote at night
they are live streaming gay sex that's
what this war is all about yeah it is
the internal rallying Cry of the Kremlin
and and by the way it's such an easy
argument to make to make fun of the
enemies like look at these clowns over
there in America they was one say no
it's not a mockery though they use it as
fear the people of Russia actually they
don't laugh at it they're like yes pu
and stay in power because we don't want
that here and so it it laughter yes but
it's more like they use it as this is
coming when they hear Lady Graham
Lindsey Graham say we're going to come
after you know this is a war of offense
what they Lindsay Graham AB kachar
Ukraine war of offense a couple years
ago um I didn't mean to interrupt you
Patrick but what I'm getting at is the
mockery by some but the rank and file
people of the Mainland of Russia are
terrified that the overtly aggressive
gay agenda is going to come into Russia
and this certainly helps the argument
look right there the sarin Ashton
cerillo is a person born a man who
became a became a woman who thinks are a
woman who is the spokesperson of the
Ukrainian Armed Forces
the true conflict unfolding in Ukraine
is the trans agenda the excesses of
modernity and traditionalism that
doesn't mean I'm on the side of Putin
that doesn't mean I'm on the side of the
Russian Federation but you have to
understand that is what is rallying
Russians domestic I fully agree with you
Charlie because two things can be true
at once number one Putin is a thug and
dictator and obviously an enemy of the
United States but we're embarrassing
ourselves when we are endorsing and Co
signing the lgbtq I A plus whatever
parts of the alphabet you want to throw
in there so yes he's wrong yes he's a
bad guy but yes he has a point he does
have a point like I mean are we allowed
to have a thought crime that like Putin
has a point are you allowed to say that
no you can't he's the worst person ever
course that doesn't mean we're endorsing
here's a fact Russia has said it's
illegal to have transgender surgeries
for kids good for Russia good honestly
that's a good thing people say no
everything Russia does is bad like that
what a stupid way to look at the world
yeah like no it's good and by the way
there's some things Russia that doesn't
do do so I got in this debate and they
say well Russia puts their political
opponents in jail yeah you're right we
would we would never put our political
dissident in general we would never have
Googs or have Donald Trump face 700
years in federal prison or lock up
people because of thought crimes are
making memes you're right Russia is so
bad that we would never put political
dissidence in federal prison or kick
down their doors with or kick down their
doors or have a drag net because someone
took a selfie in the capital maybe we're
actually more like Russia than Russia is
well you interviewed one of the most
famous Russian athletes ever the UFC
fighter fighter um norov what's it what
does he go by kabib and you asked him
how many genders are in Russia he
probably like laugh he thought about it
for like literally a half a second what
did he say I I asked him I said in
America we're very competitive we have
like a 100 different genders how many
genders you guys got in Russia and he
said we only have two it's kind of
disappointing at first you like I
thought Russia would be more competitive
but they have something called common
sense and they believe in science the
real signs not the kind of signs that
were being by the way I just want to say
one last thing I think it's sick and
disgusting that these guys did this in
the Senate hearing Room everybody knows
what should happen everybody knows
that's what goes down in the house what
should happen well he's he got fired but
I don't think the the the senator that
he works for I mean he's saying Senator
Ben Carden Ben
card personal matter should criminally
charged for defecating the Holiness and
the sacred tradition of our legislative
body he should be put in federal prison
for having gay sex and filming it yeah
cuz January January 6th was an
Insurrection what was this Tom sort of
an
aurre but no but if and and and no it's
just by the way so did you know this too
Charlie he actually did another photo
this came out today on Laura lum's uh on
her page he's taking a photo at work
like this from behind with the mirror
saying I'm waiting in my office for
Lindsey Graham to show up he post that
somebody searched in his like went back
he was posting all that stuff at work
back in the day and guess what Vinnie
what Lindsey Graham showed up he
probably did that's for sure by the way
Charlie got to ask you this disgusting
horrible what have you what happens if
it wasn't gay sex if it was of course
it's still an a it still be a federal
crime course it's desecrating of course
it is absolutely but here's what bothers
so many people about the point of it is
that he he probably thought he could get
away with it because like the whole gay
agenda gets special rights right now in
this sick world okay so let's be honest
like and then then he plays victim like
oh I feel so sad for like wow like that
is weaponized n me ask you let's do this
let's say but yes to answer your
question would be wrong let's say a
trump was president today and that
happened well he doesn't control
Congress but yeah but what what do you
think what would you think his first
reaction would be if that were to happen
What would he say what would he I would
live for that
tweet oh my God I I don't even want I
mean I would just it would be it would
be it would be Michelangelo material it
would would be something that we
remember 600 years from now and we
display in the streets of Florence and
we say You Remember When Donald Trump
reacted to the gay sex film in it would
be a wing smithonian with exctly I don't
even want to guess I don't even want to
guess what it would and mind you guys he
would tweet something like her here
things are happening in the Senate right
now he would do something like that
demic
Democrats he was just he was fired he
hasn't been charged or anything he
should be no he's Democrat at him he'll
be fine trust me he got fired cuz they
have to fire him see what happen he did
is worse than what 99% of the people on
January
6 what he did is worse than what 99% of
the people did on January by the way
that's not even that make of a shocking
statement it's I'm going to get clipped
that's why I repeated it for the
degenerates at Media Matters that
probably enjoyed the video
yeah let's let's talk about let's
transition into the next topic I thought
transition was a right appropriate War
to you here
mortgage payments on new homes have
risen 90% under Biden's presidency 90%
in 3 years average monthly mortgage
payments on new homes have surged by 90%
since the start reaching 3322 in the
third quarter of this year driven by
interest rates exceeding 7% of rising
housing prices the Federal Reserve
aggressively aggressive strategy to
raise the rates has caused it to be
where it's at right now Tom 90% so if
somebody was paying 1,600 bucks a month
1,700 bucks a month now they're paying
$3,300 a month H H how the average and
then they say the econom is doing better
gas prices are doing better all these
things are doing better how does the
average middle income family afford
raising mortgage rates by 90% well first
of all the government likes to tell a um
One Truth and One Lie the that is
inflation is down the economy is fine no
it's not the truth is inflation is
coming down the LIE is it's not good in
the economy because all prices haven't
come down houses have gone up in value
and new houses that have been built so
you have Construction in cities building
new homes out there people are trying to
get out there so the house is a bit more
expensive and then the interest rates
are more expensive because the FED
raised interest rates very aggressively
over the course of a year to tame
inflation you raise the interest rates
and inflation eventually comes down um I
won't go deeper into that but what has
happened is now people go out to buy a
new home a starter home or something and
the interest rate has effectively
doubled the payment in some places with
a national average of 90% so it's like
this is Biden nomics but all the all the
government will say hey interest rate
excuse me inflation is down the economy
is fine no it's not fine this is a net
new change and people now can't afford a
home Tom the stock market the other day
with Jerome Powell got up Market rallied
up five 600 points in a single day what
did Jerome pal say on that day that got
the market to respond the way that it
did I think inflation is reacting to the
the interest rates going up so I think
over the course of the next year
interest rates can gently come down but
they're not going to go back down to
where they were they're just going to
today mortgages are like seven and a
half depending on what you want to look
at and by the end of the year next year
all things held constant although we
have a giant election in the middle of
this they think that interest rates will
be down at 5 and 3/4 6% or something so
the market was like woohoo it's going to
cost us a little bit less for companies
to borrow money over the course of next
year and interest rates are not going to
go up any further so I called the market
to get happy because they're thinking
about big companies borrowing money to
buy new factories machines for the
factories and it's going to cost a
little less because the interest rates
will be down a little bit predictably
over next year but it doesn't mean a lot
for the consumer because they're not
coming back down to some bottoming out
that's going to take pay mortgage
payments back to where they were two
years ago so I've been following this
story very closely because I'm
constantly having conversations whether
it's better to buy whether it's better
to rent and you know who's done the best
job of basically highlighting what's
going on America right now Wall Street
Journal if you pull up Wall Street
Journal you'll see the headlines saying
things like there's never been a worst
time to buy okay and also headlines like
the math just does not add up to buying
a home right now could it be any clear
uh 47 of the top 50 metros in America
there's never been a worse time to buy
instead show the chart below by the way
there's aart below if you can find that
in 47 of the to at you 47 of the top 50
metros in America it is significantly
,000 or more cheaper to rent you're
talking La Phoenix Miami DC Boston New
York NE City there's three Metro areas
where it is actually financially better
cheaper to buy what are those three
things
Pittsburgh uh Birmingham Alabama damn
right and then I think um Jacksonville
Florida I want to say but but the the
reality is if at this point in your life
if you're looking to rent or buy and
you're not a person that sort of has
those 3% mortgages been grandfathered in
it's not even a debate at this point the
math is not on your side couple that
with the fact that mortgage rates are at
what seven seven and a quarter now I
think it went to 6.95 this week the math
is not there to buy whatsoever well is
it ever is it going to I mean he's
saying it might go down if everything
stays the same in a year but Tom it'll
never ever go back to what we were used
to I I think what it would take to go
back to what we were used to is not
something is something we've experienced
once before which is a cataclysmic event
in the economy that no one wants to see
what you also have to remember here is
for so long and I think this is
something I've been saying over and over
again uh on the podcast and other places
it has been beaten into people's head
that being a renter or renting is
somehow a dirty word no it's not it can
be a it's a personal financial choice
where you can actually conserve your
resources be more flexible of where jobs
might be or not be and be able to move
and versus and then taking savings out
that might be earning some interest and
permanently embedding them in your house
that might not go up in value and also
you know the difference there is just
the payment once that the value of the
house has gone up as if you're going to
own that house if the hail damages the
roof you know that's yours to repair
well let me add one more thing there's
the mathematical side of things and
there's the emotional side of things so
we've all been told forever and ever
that the American dream is to basically
own a peace of America own a home right
94% of Americans believe 94% of
Americans believe that owning a home is
a fixture in the American dream but yet
less than half believe they'll ever be
able to afford a home so what's
happening to the American dream people
say the American dream is dead the
American dream is dead the American
dream especially for young people
Everyone that listens to Turning Point
USA with Charlie here all the college
students out here the American dream is
not dead it has just changed it's all
about Mobility it's about all about
flexibility and it's all about low
overhead so what does that mean when you
build when you when you buy a house
what's the goal right to build equity in
your house so if you're just renting and
you can't and you don't have a mortgage
you don't have a house and you can't
build equity where can you build equity
well your Investment Portfolio your
digital wallet hell even your savings
account build that bad boy up and when
the market turns in two 5 10 years boom
your cash Rich you can buy something at
that point and maybe you have a few
extra dollars to support your church
private school or Turning Point things
that are doing good stuff in America
great plug Tom you're hired Tom that's
it Tom is hired officially campaigner
for all let's go to that with all my
heart actually let's go let's go to the
next story here Rob do you want to pull
up the picture with uh the second
greatest basketball player of all time
LeBron James can you just pull out this
picture real quick I just have to put
that up there so that's LeBron they're
singing a national anthem you see
everybody with their hands on their
chest except for the guy with the pink
sweater which is kind of weird but he's
sitting down LeBron and he walks up
doesn't stand up at all doesn't stand up
for the national anthem sits down
doesn't get up nothing Kobe has
something to say about a Rob do you have
the Kobe Covington clip and I don't know
if you've seen this or not Rob can we
even play this or not he's fighting
tonight but pbd I uh I I disagree no
Kobe's the second greatest basketball
player LeBron you put Kobe head or
LeBron LeBron's a brat he's awful you
put Kobe head of LeBron absolutely okay
but that's a different debate I'm
actually very impressed by you saying
that I'm very impressed by that not even
close but I want you to play this clip
and and folks I I if you hear what he
has to say I'm I'm curious to get your
reaction go ahead
Rob can we hear Rob if you hate America
so much and and you don't like this
country go back a little bit yeah go for
it play
again can you turn my mic on if you hate
America so much and and you don't like
this country that gave you a billion
dollars leave it or come deal with me
you go go to China go to go to these
sweat shops that you employ all these
laborers and use these women and pay
them Pennies on the dollar to make your
Millions you Lam James you're a
coward you're a spineless coward and
you're a
by the way I don't know if he said
Lan James or Lebron James but I think he
was trying to say fact that he didn't
say it right even makes me like him more
that's the best part that's the best
part he didn't even respect enough to
say his name here's a question for you
here's the question for you say the
average person's watching and saying
listen man you got 200 other stories to
pick from you're choosing this why is it
such a big deal to stand up for you know
the the you know the Ovation that
they're doing why why should he stand up
for it why is it so important for
National anth it's a huge story why is
that it's a huge story because it's a
micro of the macro the macro is we have
the richest people that have benefited
so great from this country that are
filled with ingratitude and they've
become bitter brats now is it is it like
civilizational altering that he didn't
stand or not but no it's a picture it
shows you how the people that are worth
a billion dollars that have been given
so much this country has treated LeBron
James so well this country has blessed
him Beyond his imagination and he can't
even stand because and by the way it's
not some like I didn't hear it or not no
because he has bitterness in his being
like LeBron James has never stopped
being this like resentful driven like
America systemically racist I think he
we obviously know that LeBron James has
some like inner demons he has to work
out right but contrast that with Kobe
Bryant and Michael Jordan which again
Michael Jordan better basketball player
Kobe Bryant better basketball player but
also better people I mean M Michael
Jordan would never do this are you
kidding me Michael Jordan loves his
country Michael Jordan bashes victim
mentality and LeBron James is going to
get away with it because there's this
slobbering media that supports whatever
LeBron James does and LeBron James is
more loyal to the Chinese Communist
party if XI ping walked in a room he
would say sir yes sir that's his true
master and so it is a picture of exactly
what the average Elite in America feels
which is why should I stand for this
there's nothing great about this country
and part of why we have this event
America Fest is that the everyday person
the plumber the electrician the welder
the parent the student we are done with
the most powerful people using their
power on a downward campaign to destroy
our country like leave the country
LeBron like leave the country you have a
billion dollars like we don't need you
like the country has not been enriched
by your dribbling around and shooting
you're not allowed to say that because
it's racist I don't care that's what you
do okay you have a talent for basketball
you're a bad person we don't need you in
fact the country probably be better if
you went to Mainland China like you I
can't think your school is not even
functioning in Cleveland like kids are
killing other kids you know he's like
he's not even a good philanthropies and
so look I I get pretty fired up about
this because we used to be a nation 100
years ago you could say what you want
about Carnegie and rockerfeller and JP
Morgan and melon who made billions of
dollars the robber barons right say what
you want about them but they love the
country they loved America rockerfeller
loved America JP Morgan loved America
now the people that have it best absent
Elon Musk he is the exception praise God
for him McKenzie Bezos LeBron James
Loren pal jobs Reed Hoffman Mark
bennyhoff Reed
Hastings they don't love the country
that gave them so much and we are here
in America Fest that say go to hell go
to hell we're taking back this country
yeah great Point Charlie Adam yeah I I
mean this isn't I don't know what
LeBron's going to do but this is an
inflection point in his career and his
life if LeBron actually loved America
and he actually paid attention to what
people are saying about him this would
be a great time for him to say look I'm
LeBron James I love the hell out of
America this made me the billionaire
this made me the man I am imagine LeBron
giving a speech like like that like
Jordan famously said I don't pick sides
Democrats Republicans why because
Republicans buy tennis shoes too but
LeBron is an opportunity here to be like
you know what F all of you I love
America but I don't see that speech
coming of that's the problem and then
I'll add one more thing and shout out to
you guys here and this is the problem
that I have with my Democrat buddies out
there it's become abundantly clear that
Republicans and conservatives love
America more than liberals and certainly
more than progressives and that's Bas
hate America that's a bad thing man
America Fest should be people of all
political affiliations if we had this
event 50 years ago we would have Kennedy
Democrats and Rockefeller Republicans
it's not good that America Fest is
partisan it's 100% it's true it's real
but like loving the country is
considered radical and hating the
country is considered fashionable yeah
you get extra tokens and points in Aspen
Elite Society if you hate America you
get you're at like weird looks if you
say this country is amazing are you
saying you're not going to askp him for
Christmas oh no I I don't I'm invited to
a lot of Aspen parties at New Year's on
Red Mountain Patrick these people that
go to Aspen you got to be careful with
by the
way bunkport Martha's Vineyard Aspen Sun
Valley I've been to all your vacation
not that nice guys don't follow my
Instagram stories during
Christmas you are one of the elites PB
but you but you made a good point
Charlie and it's like he's obviously the
the China situation we see with other
athletes too who was the who was the WWE
guy that John Cena John Cena stuck up
for Taiwan he had to speak in mandering
to the camera and apologize to the to
his to his Masters and you nailed it and
it's just I'm sick and tired of this
anti like by the way he joined the NBA
when he was in high school LeBron what
what struggle what what what have we
done so wrong to and I think when Trump
God willing Trump wins that attitude of
people saying like a b Midler or Barbara
strien or share if Trump wins I'm
leaving this country we have to put in
law that if you said that get the out
when when it happens you got to leave
you said it your word is binding Bye by
the way I want to contrast that with
something though that the attitude here
if the bad guys win we're not going
anywhere nope that's what makes us
different is that I'm going to raise my
grandkids here yeah it might get like to
be a a dystopian hellscape I'm not
leaving you can't force me out I'm never
going to give up I'm going to be an
annoying mosquito in your ear for as
long as I have
not going to leave yes that's Charlie's
Wolf of Wall Street speech right there I
love it which I love but I I I I'm the
what's going on with Jen Z when he we
see them sort of parading for Hamas
there's something there and and at the
tip of the spirits like hatred and
disdain for the country that you live in
and that you're born in and you're
looking around the world and being like
oh they're all doing it so much better
show me a perfect country and you know
what move to a more perfect country if
that's where you're at but you today you
brought up a stat and your awesome
speech sick speech give it up for
Charlie speech today by the way sick
speech so
sick 2032 2032 2032 2032 remember that
number I Lego but you said about high
school high school students Charlie are
tending to be more conservative now
because they're probably seeing what's
going on in colleges beond scho explain
that yeah so it's the hill.com uh
conservative poll High School boys most
conservative in 50 years I I think you
can pull it up but put High School boys
conservative gen Z the headline isn't as
good actually as the data yeah High
School boys are the most conservative
they've been in 50 years uh young ladies
are pretty liberal that's it yeah High
School boys are trending conservative I
think there's a really great poll that
accompanies this uh they did a couple
stories at the hill.com um but yeah look
the that's it that's it yeah um so
that's 12th grade girls and then you go
down to high school boys oh yeah the
girls are it's not good um and then the
boys you got to really scroll you know
they bury the lead here Patrick they
don't even have it for the the boys um
or they got rid of it the the boys are
the most conserved they've been in 50
years and for a lot of reasons look
young men are first and foremost pbd I
got it I this is it look 50 years most
conservative in 50 years you go back to
1975 they haven't been that conservative
wow pbd you deserve a lot of credit a
lot of young men look up to you pbd a
lot of young men look up to you and
you're a great role model for them
you're a great father you're a great
husband you're a great entrepreneur but
you're part of a community of really
outspoken men the Tate brothers which
you know aren't people aren't you know
all fans of them but they've done a lot
of good calling out a lot of nonsense
Joe Rogan Jordan Peterson Matt Walsh you
know you kind of list them across the
board 14 15 16 17y old young boys are
gravitating towards this genre of
content Unapologetic Alpha mail uh High
te right loving the country Free Speech
it's okay if you disagree let's get into
the arena of different ideas and it is
freaking out the left and because this
this they're getting their news from
social media over the top podcasting
itbd one of the hope at turning USA we s
day are going to shock the world I'm
telling you they're going to shock the
world this coming November I'm telling
you they're going to shock the world
Charlie actually so I want to make sense
of these numbers because there there's
actually a story that just came out in
the New York Post that actually is very
worrisome okay okay because it's
basically tells this story and you
talked about have kids get married do it
as young as freaking possible the
fertility so if you look at that story
no no no not in the fertility go back to
those numbers real quick Rob so just
break this down for me young men are
getting more conservative and young
women are getting more liberal that's
right okay so here's the story that the
New York Post talks about red flags in
dating okay oh yeah here's the number
the most common red flag for men um
2third agreeing to this were women who
had communist and socialist ideology so
they're basically like yo I ain't
with these Communists that that
should be the number one daty criteria
by the way never date a commi fully
agree never dat but how about this for
women
75% would not date a magga republican so
here's what's going on here the men are
getting more conservative the women are
getting more liberal how the hell are
they ever going to get together Charlie
and make those babies you want now would
makes sense why you're not married yet
oh my God I got
it Republican it explains why so many
women are becoming lesbians I'm not
kidding it explains why no I mean
obviously because they want what they
want which is they want liberalism so
they go after what is liberal which is
single women and they they're like I
don't want a magga republic let me get
this straight so you don't want a man
that's going to treat you well and
protect you and provide for the family
and is going to nurture and raise good
kids and love the country and you know
live the American dream like what
exactly do you want and the reason is
because they've been propagandized by
the media by Academia by their friends
by the music that they consume that
there's something toxically masculine
and I don't believe them actually deep
down even the most liberal neurotic
woman she dreams of a strong muscular
High te man in her life the problem is
here's what it is the root of modern
liberalism and Tucker says all the time
is these are young girls with daddy
issues it's what it is right mad at dad
my dad watches too much Fox News like
okay get over yourself honestly mad at
dad is the driver of like the broken
politics that we see right now so how
does this reconcile itself well honestly
you know at America Fest I could tell
you the young women here they want magga
Republicans I can tell you they want
magga Republicans and and honestly and
they don't have small hands either
Charli that eventually we're just going
to outbreed these people we are I mean
we're just going to out we're going to
have more babies in 20 years from now
they're going to say why is the country
so right-wing well you were too busy
having abortions and having gay sex and
not wanting to get married and we got
married and had kids and we will
repopulate the spe by the way I'm not
kidding by by the way by the way by the
way you you can be left right center
logical emotional that is by far the
most logical argument you just gave
statistically that cannot be argued
because it's proven it's going to happen
period it's just going to take two
decades it's going to take two de give
us some time everybody buy us some time
buy the Constitution sometime you know
America Fest by the way if you look at
the young people here yeah check back 20
years from now it'll be the of Wyoming
right I mean Mormon levels of children
will come out of America key though we
got to have Mormon level of kids well
yes we got to get our testosterone rates
High young ladies got to get married and
we have to have the babies and by the
way I mean the the the the BET David
family you guys are doing your part but
no all joking aside having children is
not a left-wing value it's not important
them it's just the data like I'm not
even reading into so maybe maybe if
that's what you're saying maybe let them
keep talking about abortion and let them
keep doing this kind of stuff because
they're just going to get is that kind
of what you're saying yes and no the
point is this abortion is a moral crime
on the country right I don't wish that
upon anyone but the the the truth of the
matter is this is that if leftwing
people keep on not having kids whether
it be by abortion or you know being in
homosexual relationships how exactly
they think this thing is going to work I
mean what this is why honestly they want
to import so many people from the third
world into this country which is
backfiring because they have to have
some way to try to stop all these right
Wingers from having babies I got two
stories I want to do before we wrap up
we got two more stories before we wrap
up how many guys here are familiar with
crisper cast n who's familiar with
chrisper it's Gene altering technology
alter technology a little creepy so
Vinnie are you following the story Clos
Brandon Brandon hooked me up okay so
check this out imagine if in 2012 this
lady from UC Berkeley comes up with this
concept called uh crisp uh cast 9 okay
crisper C9 2013 crisper gets started
this company 2016 they go public their
stock goes all the way up to nearly $200
today it's like A4 and a half billion a
company when was the date that they just
got there on December 8th uh FDA
approved the first crisper treatment CLE
cell disease what this Gene editing does
you can literally imagine going to the
doctor you and your wife and you say
doc doc ask you question Vinnie how tall
would you guys like your son to be um
6'4 okay great boom uh what color eyes
would you want your son to have
blue yeah okay great um what color hair
would you want your son to have blonde
great you literally order what you want
your kid to have and they put those
genes by editing it for you to have
exactly the baby you want to have now
you may say p there's no way that's
possible how long ago was it where
people started deciding how many people
would say you know what I don't want to
have three different pregnancies doc can
we do one pregnancy three kids if you
had money you would go and say what
let's have triplets how long has that
been going on Town 20 years with the um
uh invitro fertilization but watch this
they can plant multiple 20 years is not
a long time you're manipulating having
more kids so these guys sat there and
said if we can manipulate that what if
we can manipulate the exact type of a
kid you can have now here's the thing
they tested on a couple hundred people
they tested lymphoma so this Gene
editing can actually do some good which
is cancer cure AIDS cure a lot of
different things
but when you think about Gene editing
Charlie what's the first thing you think
about with this invention of chrisper
cast n you mean I think of eugenics
first and foremost um and I mean I first
of all I don't trust the technology and
then who's going to be in charge of it
look the only possible hope is that
potentially there are some people that
are born with some really really
unfortunate stuff okay really
unfortunate stuff that if we could find
some way to limit that or eliminate it
praise God what I mean I mean um someone
who's boring with MLS right luk
Garrick's disease right that that
there's a way to get rid of it but look
um this is this is going in a direction
that I think is very dangerous almost
End Time stuff for those of us that
follow the Bible where this is not about
correcting this is about designing this
is about taking a role of God and trying
to design the human being you want I'm
sorry I'm not on board for it right
absent an intervention that could save
somebody's life from a life-threatening
ill for example if there are two parents
that both carry um a recessive gene and
they know for certain a child has a one
in4 chance of having a dehab
life-threatening disease okay I think
there could be a moral argument for that
but saying that I want to customize my
child like I'm going to you know build a
teddy bear workshop I think that's
really sick I really do Tom or a
nefarious country just deciding they
want to build um a super race superum
that's what than that can you give him
that link about China that they're
building captain americaas in China as
of 2020 when we found out
they don't want women they just want I
need five okay in 18 years from now I
need to have 5,000 super soldiers just
males order them up by by the way this
is it China has done human testing to
create biologically Clone War ened super
soldiers says top official US
intelligence agency did immediately
respond to request for comment about
whether China seeks super soldiers for
like those in such films as Captain
America they now have Gene editing to
build Captain America type solders
in China uh Adam for you thoughts on
this here well never underestimate
people's ability to just have their own
self-interests basically endorsed so
people are going to do what the hell
ever they want to do couple things if
our enemy is doing it and making a super
race of humans we're going to kind of
have to meet them at their own game here
or we're going to get blown out of the
water I totally agree with Charlie where
like every year I go to the Special
Olympics my father had cerebral paly it
was a family thing we would go there he
had mentally he was 100% he was good he
was sharp he did math like pbd
physically he almost look he had a
stroke but I would go to the Special
Olympics every year and it was the most
rewarding empathetic like reality check
where like I'm a 15-year-old kid with
pimples they're like yeah you don't have
it that bad buddy these people
have it bad if you can change those
people lives people cerebral cerebral
poliy people with major issues people
with all sorts of just autoimmune issues
everything if you can change that you're
changing people's lives aming I would be
honest I'm be honest Patrick I'm going
to be very skeptical about both the
ethics and the execution of this
technology but if it can you know help
people from life-threatening diseases
you you know what it is when you think
about Gene editing there's a handful of
movies you think about you got aium you
got X-Men you got uh fly you got uh
Jurassic Park that's all Gene editing
right so in the hands of the wrong
person they're capable of doing a lot of
bad last but not least story before we
wrap up Tom uh Dei it's not looking good
for Dei a bunch of people on De on
Twitter are talking about Dei Elam mus
talked about it Oklahoma governor signs
order effectively Banning diversity
programs as public colleges at public
colleges okay finally somebody's
stepping up yes let me read the story I
got the biggest Applause from the crowd
interesting Oklahoma governor Kevin stit
signed an executive order effectively
Banning diversity equity and inclusion
Dei programs at public colleges and
agencies prohibiting them from State
funds or resources for Di initiatives
and ordering the dismo of non-critical
personnel this order is effective
immediately with compliance expected by
May 31st of 2024 Charlie what do you
think about the story I think it's
amazing uh I think every red State
Governor should follow suit uh anybody
in power should get rid of Dei
immediately mediately uh Dei is a
Marxist program that's infiltrated it is
anti-white institutionalized um and Elon
Musk is now one of the most anti- Dei
spokespeople of the West and praise God
for Elon of doing that he says Dei
should be rearranged to deie uh because
it is saying it is dying look Elon Musk
calls diversity equ inclusion morally
wrong propaganda words for racism sexism
changing the target class doesn't make
it right good for you Elon Musk we need
more people with wealth and with power
and a platform to speak out against uh
Dei so I love that Governor S is doing
this it shouldn't have taken this long
um they call you a racist ignore them
when they say that get rid of the Dei
office go back to meritocracy Dei is at
odds with the promise of the American
Constitution it's at odds you cannot
have a meritocracy and have Dei so
choose choose which way America do you
want a segregated Society do you want
Christmas parties like in Boston where
white people are not allowed that is Dei
do you want black only dormitories that
is Dei do you want bonuses based on skin
color that is Dei or do you want work
ethic and Merit to be rewarded that is
what built this country we have to get
back to it so right now we have to go on
a nonstop deletion campaign and get rid
of every single Dei office in America
immediately Charlie can I ask you a
follow up on that great point so you
know they say there's a difference
between perception and reality for the
people that aren't really following
what's going on with Dei or ESG
everything that's sort of you know in in
in our world for the average person when
they hear diversity it's like all right
cool diversity that's great equity yeah
we all want a piece of equity oh it's
great inclusion exact inclusion let's be
incl be included so on the surface like
you know if you're a liberal college
girl like whatever like most people
aren't paying attention to policies
they're T they're they're paying
attention to personality and just
basically
Optics where did people like get give
people the the the the reality of what
this is meaning the average person out
there thinks it's great Charlie how
racist of you to basically say Dei is
bad what would you say say to those
people well I mean first of all
understand what Dei actually is it's
Marxism by another name it is race
Marxism it is trying to destroy what
exists strip it down and put in a
completely different type of society it
it is race pref you know it's it's race
preference and so you have to ask
somebody do you think your skin color
matters to your worth it's one of the
most important simple honest questions
in America today if yes you're a bigot I
have no I have no time for you you
should be like no actually your skin
color doesn't matter that much of course
there's racial differences they don't
matter actually really at all they don't
matter about your character or your soul
or your agency like and by the way how
how shallow I mean people are much
deeper than how they look like a lot
deeper and just to kind of put people
back into sectarian tribes is regression
so what Dei does it is ret tribalize
Society into a new India style cast
system where you can never Escape no
matter how much good you do no matter
how much you study no matter how early
you work no matter how much you try to
improve your life you're trapped you're
in an open a prison Dei creates America
into an open air prison that if you're
white you can never Escape it you have
to constantly apologize you have to
constantly go on a knee and it's a by
the way if you want to live in that type
of country go to South Africa literally
that whole country is built on Dei and
CRT it's an entire country that is based
on racial separation and revenge against
whites they have political rallies where
they say kill the boar kill the boore
the whole country is built on racial
resentment what the Revival that will
come to this country and pbd you're
doing a great job helping lead and what
we're doing here at America Fest and
turning point USA the Revival will go
back to a preference on meritocracy
character not skin color agency not
tribe that has always been what has made
America different and exceptional well
said Charlie how much similarity like
when you hear BLM black lives matter on
the surface it's like yeah of course
they matter but the reality is was a
Marxist organization that was basically
trying to tear down the nuclear family
is that basically the parallel to and
again don't take my word for it look at
Elon Musk Dei Must Die the point was to
end discrimination not replace with a
different discrimination that's the
world's wealthiest man he's saying it
because it's true it's not like he has
more he has to go make more money or
he's going to win favor or friends and
look they they took advantage of the
best intentions of the American people
to your point yeah inclusion who who
wants to be non-inclusive right or
diversity now they never actually mean
diversity because they want everyone to
look different but think the same they
don't mean they don't believe in
intellectual diversity or Viewpoint
diversity or religious diversity they
want just skin color diversity and they
want ideological totalitarianism that's
the most important thing so look Dei is
against it is I Dei is a virus and I'll
say this and people hate when I say it
but it's true Dei is a much more
dangerous virus to America than Co ever
was and Dei is now lasting much longer
than Co and the top priority of this
conference and our podcast and all of us
together is to unite our forces if
you're a Libertarian conservative
Democrat I don't care we must unite and
kick the Dei virus out of America as
quickly as possible so it and it took a
South African made American Elon Musk to
understand how it works there to
basically call this out Tom no Amen to
that you you were asking Adam you know
where do people see it well people are
seeing it when teachers Public School
teachers have to take a vow and it's a
vow or they have to sign a document that
adjusts their behavior at school so
people are seeing it come out saying
wait a minute why do I have to do this
I'm a 25- year teacher why do I have to
take this vow against this and this that
it's showing up everywhere critical race
Theory one of the first tendences is
that the instant you're born if you're
born white or Asian you critical race
Theory are inherently racist and you
haven't lived a moment of your life and
had a rational thought you're you're
you're you just arrived here you know
Welcome To Earth enjoy your stay and so
when you take a look at these tenants
they're absolutely ludicrous and you you
can boil it down like this your dad goes
into an emergency room I don't care what
color the doctor is how many bypasses
has he done and can he saved my Dad's
life that's the only thing I care about
that's a meritocracy and that's where it
needs to go and Charlie God bless you
for everything that turning point is
trying to do to raise the awareness and
be such a loud voice exactly what Elon
Musk says let's not take one
discrimination which is bad and and just
replace it with another discrimination
Which is far worse yeah I love that you
know it's it's amazing I never the idea
of somebody feeling sorry for you should
be an unattractive idea like you
shouldn't like pity again a good this
goes back to this book that was written
many years ago Rob if you can pull up
the chart power versus Force just go to
Power versus Force chart uh this is
something everybody ought to look at you
ought to go through this click on the
the one with the the one to the right of
it go to one right there click on that
one zoom in just zoom in don't do
anything but click and just zoom in a
little bit there you go and go left look
look at this from the lowest level of
Consciousness to the highest one zoom
out a little bit the lowest level where
you don't perform in a good place is
shame then guilt then apathy then grief
then fear then desire then anger then
Pride the first level where you finally
have power is when you have courage then
neutrality which you're able to
entertain opposing ideas then you're
willing to have the discussion then
you're accepting the differences you're
able to reason with other people you
love joy peace and if you make it to
Enlightenment if you can constantly be
aware of this to not fall for of Shame
guilt apathy grief fear desire anger and
pride and have the courage to change
future looks bright and it looks like
you guys are doing that with Turning
Point can I just say one thing ABS I
just want to give a shout out to our
amazing attendees here at amfest you
guys are the best you guys are
unbelievable praise God you guys are
doing such a great job and just a thing
uh if you guys are watching on YouTube
YouTube is playing a lot of games with
our Charlie Kirk Channel if you guys
could go subscribe and like a couple
videos it will break us out they're
really put the link below in theat that
that would help us it would bless us at
home if you guys just go to the Charlie
Kirk Channel they're shadowbanning our
videos right now it's totally clear we
were averaging 5 million Real views you
know short videos a day went down to
5,000 like nothing like 10 it's unbel
it's obvious Shadow band got a strike
over something wrong the way to break
out of it though is if just people go
organically to the page and it spikes
the content back up so if you guys could
do that it would we would deeply deeply
app get off just go subscribe comment
watch a couple of the post Charlie again
thank you for the invite had a great
time with the audience here thank you
everybody take care we'll do it again
next week bye-bye bye-bye
bye-bye was a
great that flew by that was awesome this
was awesome and PB you're staying
staying around for tomorrow I am I am is
is is tomorrow or now you don't know yet
you and me no of course tomorrow you and
I are in the morning yes what do you
mean
our